was that wrong as well
it's all falling apart okay
[Music]
okay people this is magnus back
with some tactics frenzy i'm gonna try
two things today we're gonna try um
random mode as i usually do and then
we're gonna try the hard mode as well
uh let's start with random to
get the juices flowing so first one is a
simple mate in two
second one is amazing three okay
we win the queen i think when the when
they win the queen back but we're fine
what's this one bishop b5 does not seem
legal to me
oh it's queen of three
very nice that was quite pretty a little
fork right here
wow i guess we just keep it simple huh
my f5 take back retain the extra
material
here we just it's nice when the solution
is also the best positional move we just
advanced the pawns and then
accidentally we win a piece that was a
nice win of a queen
checkmate let me see rook c7
seems to win a queen we'll run with the
king
and then we give checkmate okay
a lot of pieces hanging but we take and
then
take again looks like we're
winning a queen here with a little
i don't know what you call it oh
kasparov
queen b2 that's it right
we have to do that take it
king b2 take it
king b2 and queen b3 next is made
yep very nice
well done gary
mate in two
here we protect against mate seems the
only way
good stuff good stuff check sorry take
everything
let's just give a check on b7 to be
extra precise and then
we take the rook
um what's the story
queen d6 king
rooty one no this doesn't seem to work
i think we should probably take the
bishop immediately
our first mistake of the day
not good
was that wrong as well
it's all falling apart okay little fork
rook f1 seems to win
[Music]
oh this is nice rook f7 bishop f4 and
then we have c4 with a little fork
rook dna twinning queen
oh nice roof d6 we take back on e1
and then we need this going to be mates
if we take d7 rook d1
knight d5 seems seems about right
okay when the bishop
win the rock
i like queen d4 i think that's more
flashy than good so what if we take
ambush buffet
didn't see that one queen before
rook c6 bishop bc6 the mirror queen b2
has a threat
i don't know looks good well
now we just take it bishop c5 and we
win in exchange
just take it and then run
jack jack push knight of 7
seems easy enough
drop the queen
okay just a simple rock win
take the rook right there's no no real
counter play
okay it's got to be bishop somewhere
bishop g4 probably and then discovered
jack
on the queen regardless of where the
king goes
okay nice little mate here
and a little skewer
should define i think we just take take
the rook actually
taken c5 and then we would win c7
yeah okay g5 knight moves we have a fork
okay just repeat
okay this one is a bit tricky
um don't have the time
where is my solution
no that was wrong oh wrong oh
this is uh i think uh the game
v2 go fun forest first one
okay r7
h4 take it
push
i guess we're taking f6 h5 drop the
bishop
and win the bishop rook f5
g4 should be two and there will be
stalemate
oh come on come on
where's the trick oh that's the trick
four wins the night take the queen
of the rook oh i guess that was wrong
check check check mate
nope okay
what's the trick
oh a3 i guess okay
nice
[Music]
no was that wrong
that wasn't very good was it
oh well too much talk
too slow we try again
at hard mode coming up very soon
stay tuned
[Music]
you